but in the first instance the return of
the feeling heart into itself is to be
taken to mean than it has an actual
existence as an individual it is the
pure heart which for us or in itself has
found itself and is inwardly satiated
for although for itself and it's feeling
the essential being is separated from it
yet this feeling is in itself a feeling
of self it has felt the object of its
pure feeling and this object is itself
thus it comes forward here is self
feeling or as an actual consciousness
existing on its own account in this
return into self there comes into view
its second relationship that of desire
and work in which consciousness finds
confirmation of that inner certainty of
itself which we know it has attained by
overcoming and enjoying the existence a
lien to it then as existence of the form
of independent things but the unhappy
consciousness merely that finds itself
desiring and working it is not aware
that define itself active in this way
implies that it is in fact certain of
itself and that its feeling of the alien
existence is this self feeling since it
is not explicitly aware of this
certainty its inner life really remains
a still uncomplete self certainty that
confirmation which it would receive
through work and enjoyment is therefore
equally and complete in other words it
must set itself they must have self
senate not this confirmation so that it
may indeed find it in it confirmation
but only confirmation of what it is for
itself that is of its divided nests
we just witnessed in the previous
paragraph this interplay what Hegel has
called the infinite or the pure heart
and it's attempt to bring together the
two sides of consciousness that lead it
to be the unhappy consciousness so this
I mean this this heart is really an
expression of the unhappy consciousness
here in in paragraph 218 Hegel is going
to say okay well we we saw that there's
an impasse there can we move in a
different direction from this now this
theme is going to show up in later parts
of the phenomenology so we don't want to
forget about it
and say oh we're going to leave it
behind at this point but he's going to
give us a little bit of review he says
in the first instance the return of the
feeling heart into itself right so why
does it return into itself he tells us a
little bit more there it was not able to
attain to the unchangeable Universal in
the mode of thought it was able to do so
in a kind of grasping way that he had to
do with with feeling right but feeling
is mutable feeling is not really the
thing by which we're going to grasp the
unchangeable for Hegel entities because
feeling is feeling feeling is shifting
so he says the the feeling heart returns
into itself it's kicked back you might
say and that process of being kicked
back is actually going to be productive
for it so this is one of those lessons
that it's learning where it doesn't like
it at the time but it's actually
benefiting from it he says it's taken to
mean it has an actual existence as an
individual so the person becomes
conscious other individuality and we're
going to see this theme running
throughout oh well the next four or five
paragraphs in particular so he says it's
the pure heart which for us for us or in
itself has found itself in as inwardly
satiated now if it stays satiated
progressing further right that's not
going to be an issue whereas we're gonna
see and he says for although it for
itself in its feeling the essential
being a separated from it right the
central being being the unchangeable
Universal yet this feeling is in itself
a feeling of self now what does he mean
there there is feeling going on in two
different ways there's feeling is sort
of attending out towards the the
infinite the unchangeable Universal it
realizes itself is infinite though even
they have feelings so there's there's a
double feeling going on in feeling
pretty typical Hegel right nothing is
ever completely simple there's always a
duality implied and that exposed the net
so he says it has felt the object of its
pure feeling and this object is itself
so what do we have here
it's so close to realizing that this
unchangeable Universal that it's trying
to grasp is actually its own
consciousness which somehow is still
united with this other part of itself
that it feels to really be itself but a
dumb going to get it so we're going to
see a transition to come in the MSE says
it comes forward as self feeling or as
an actual consciousness existing on its
own account in this returning to self
there comes into view its second
relationship right so this is the first
relationship this is right here the
second relationship the moments of
desire and work and Hegel is going to
talk both in sort of the abstract or
substance desire and and work and he's
also going to talk specifically about
the person individual desiring and
working or or laboring now why turn this
way is there some sort of internal
necessity to this whole process well
legal men
that already when he set up this schema
for us in the earlier paragraph so we
don't have to rehearse that this is the
the second moment the second
relationship what is going to come out
of the preamps that displays the
necessity it's not going to do it in
this paragraph but it will and the
following paragraphs as it unfolds
he says consciousness finds confirmation
of the inner certainty of itself which
we know it is attained by overcoming and
enjoying the existence a lien to it
what is that existence in the form of
independent things desires and work as
we saw in the master-slave dialectic and
as we also saw in the earlier shapes of
consciousness in this section desire and
work allow the person to nullify the
independent things nullifying that mask
independent making them deepen there's a
dialectic here of course because in
order to work on that and you have to
adapt yourself to that miss or an extent
one way you can do that is by putting
somebody else to work you know the stoic
gets beyond master and slave we've seen
all that right what Hegel wants to say
here though is that this way to when
it's happens this gives a kind of self
certainty or let's let's call it instead
a self confirmation by asserting myself
over the object over the independent
thing that I work upon that I desire and
that I therefore then enjoy right I
cracked him that's open and I eat them
up and the nuts aren't eating me I'm
eating the nuts it's now like you know
Yakov Smirnoff and in Soviet Russia that
nuts eat you or the can of soda needs
you it drinks you or think
those sorts of things the swimming pool
cleans you instead of used swimming
cleaning the swimming pool them swimming
in it
right so what happens here works for the
realm of objects doesn't work for what
consciousness is attempting to do here
well what is consciousness attempting to
do it's attempting to grasp the
unchangeable universal it keeps on
skirting itself away from is this going
to work
Hegel says no not at this point he says
the unhappy consciousness merely finds
itself desiring and working it doesn't
find itself attaining to the
satisfaction that it wants it is not
aware that to find itself active in this
way implies that it is in fact certain
of itself see with the enjoyment you can
say aha I know I'm in charge here
right you don't have that enjoyment
happening here you said desiring and
working and it doesn't seem to have a
terminus so there isn't that sense of
confirmation at least not explicitly for
him for the individual here he says it's
not aware that to find itself active in
this way implies that it is in fact
certain in itself it's feeling of the
alien existence is this self feeling so
what is this this alien existence it
really the self the self that is
desiring and working aiming at some
object beyond the desire and the work
not realizing that that is itself it's
not going to realize it for quite a
while ahead right so he says because
it's not explicitly aware of this it's
in and life still remains an incomplete
saw certainty the confirmation that it
would have and enjoyment is therefore
incomplete so it must set that not this
confirmation so that it may indeed find
it in confirmation but only confirmation
of what it is for itself that is it's
divided this
so that we get confirmation that unites
all of this against the division is
being placed here between the active
individual being and whatever this is
that it's after that we've been calling
the unchangeable
the world of actuality to which desire
and work are directed is no longer for
this consciousness something
intrinsically not something merely to be
set aside and consumed but something
like that consciousness itself an
actuality broken into which is only from
one aspect intrinsically now but from
another aspect is also a sanctified
world it is the form of the unchangeable
for this has retained individuality and
because as the unchangeable it is a
universal it's individuality has in
general the significance of all
actuality
and paragraph 219 Hagel is going to
introduce another wrinkle get into what
he's just developed in the previous
paragraph 218 and I don't even have the
individual who was desiring and working
may be enjoying maybe not
definitely desiring and and working here
and Hegel talks about the world now why
does he do that well you know we saw
that that attempt to try to destroy the
the object and have self certain day we
talked about that already we saw that
it's not able to do that with the the
other part of the unhappy consciousness
the part that's projected out and now
we're going to find out that this
bifurcation is actually occurring within
the world or the actualities out for the
vehicle kites right in German itself the
object for for consciousness so Hegel is
going to tell us the world of actuality
to which desire and work are directed
now because why because this is an
actually existing individual who he has
to hold down a job so that he or she can
actually eat and enjoy and acquire and
do what they they want to do and they
have desires to be an existing
individual means to actually have
tangible although perhaps infinite as
well desires so they are turned out
towards the the world the world of
objects of seemingly independent things
and we saw that it's very easy to you
know undo to to destroy literally or to
some weight because the term that's
actually used here is up to behave them
right you know that's that term that
haigo uses for making some sort of a
super session that we're sublation where
we want to translate a transcending it
that's what we do to the world of
objects that we engage with so he says
that the world of actuality
of things there's no longer something
intrinsically no now what does that mean
well there's a side to the things that
gets intrinsically no because that's why
we're able to to nullify that's why
we're able to say no as we say yes I'm
going to consume you right but the world
reveals another side now this is really
interesting isn't he says something like
that consciousness itself is what the
world is an actuality broke it into so
there is a brokenness on a part of
consciousness there's also a break
within the world a break into what well
hey leaves is a term that Miller is
translating and sanctified the hiding
zone well you know a holy world is a way
that you could translate a very close to
the cognate we might say sanctified or
we might say made sacred right this is
the difference between the sacred and
the profane and why is part of the world
or a side of the world than sanctified
this is where it gets really really
interesting Hegel says that here you
know it's a sanctified world it is the
form of the unchangeable what does that
mean he plays this out the unchangeable
means being the universal but the
universal has already itself taken on
individuality individuality as a
universal or as he's calling an
individuality in general now there's
something that's being a little bit
obscured by the translation here when
when as we say the the sanctified world
the sanctified actuality this dimension
is actually the form of the unchangeable
what he was saying there is it's the
Gestalt so this is
itself perhaps we could say a shape of
consciousness but it's a shape of
consciousness that is to a certain
extent getting away from the individual
when really all of this implicitly is
consciousness
if consciousness were aware of being an
independent consciousness and the world
of actuality work for it an absolute
nullity then work in enjoyment it would
attain to a feeling of its independence
since the world of actuality would be
nullified by itself but since this
actuality is for consciousness the form
of the unchangeable it is unable of
itself to nullify it on the contrary
since it does succeed in setting it at
naught and enjoying it this comes about
through the unchangeable z-- itself
having surrendered its embodied form and
having relinquished it for the enjoyment
of the consciousness consciousness on
its part likewise makes its appearances
in actuality but also is divided within
itself and in its work and enjoyment
this divided miss displays itself as
breaking it up into a relation to the
world of actuality or a being which is
for itself and into a being that is in
itself that relation to actuality is the
changing of it or working on the being
for self which belongs to the individual
consciousness as such but in this
relation it is also in itself or has
intrinsic being this aspect belongs to
the unchangeable Beyond and consists of
faculties and powers a gift from an
alien source which the unchangeable
makes over to consciousness to make use
of
now here in paragraph 220 we're going to
see a really interesting transformation
take place an important step in the
dialectic that you want to pay very
close attention to that the previous
paragraph have been getting us set up
for and remember what are we talking
about here we're talking about the mode
or the relation in which the unhappy
consciousness as individuality is trying
to grasp the the essence the the
importance the unchangeable whatever we
want to call it through the moment of
desire and work and what it's trying to
grasp corresponds to the the
unchangeable that is taken on
individuality now all of this is going
to come together let's see how that
happens so it says that consciousness
itself is related to the world or to
actuality right it says that
consciousness we're aware of being in a
dependent consciousness and the world of
actuality work for an absolute nullity
then it didn't work and enjoyment it
would attain to a feeling of its
independence we've already gone past
that right since this world of actuality
would be nullified by it something would
reveal itself as no but we see now that
the world or actuality of course has
that that aspect of the holy the
sanctified the essential what is really
real and why because it is the gestalt
it is the form of the unchangeable
resting beneath it so he says because
this actuality is that it is unable to
those consciousness towards desired word
is unable to nullify it what's going to
happen though it looks like
consciousness has reached an impasse
it's digging in and just can't get any
further why because it doesn't have the
tools or you know what it's working
again I was too hard
well now what it's working on as an
agency is going to do something on its
own part what is it going to do is it
going to simply change
justice by itself No is it going to
disappear to the - nothing you can't do
that either
is it going to just a wave a magic wand
and make everything all right no what
does it do instead does Hinkle says and
this is really quite interesting he says
that consciousness does succeed in
setting this at not why it's able to
enjoy it why because the unchangeable
which you would think would mean it can
never change at all it can never undergo
anything I can never suffer anything
right
it surrenders as Hinkle says it's
embodied Gestalt it's embodied form its
embodied shape - who - the individual
consciousness what are we talking about
here we're talking about remember we
have the essential the universal as
itself an individual now giving over
it's very individuality to the ordinary
person who is consciousness for
enjoyment so that that ordinary
consciousness can grasp itself as being
something that does matter something
that does get important something that
is essential this is really quite
dramatic you may not see this through
all the metaphysical verbiage but that's
what he's talking about there and so he
says consciousness on its part makes its
appearance is in actuality but it's
going to be divided within itself so
we're still going to see this division
what is the division it's into the for
itself and the in itself two aspects of
consciousness here and I have to say
people have been asking questions about
for itself it in itself on earlier
videos when they show up Hegel does not
always mean exactly the same thing by
them at every single stage in the
dialectic it's not like saying John Paul
starts Being and Nothingness where
the fundamental categories of being
these are dynamic categories so what is
the for itself going to be here it says
it breaks itself up into a relation to
the world of actuality or a being which
is for itself right and how does it for
itself manifest itself through here in
desire and work right this is how
consciousness is for itself through
desiring and working through through
changing things in the world of
actuality working upon what is it going
to be in itself well this is where we
get something still yeah happen or
perhaps it's the same movement maybe
this is what surrendering its embody
state where its Gestalt actually means
what is the in itself for the individual
consciousness it's what is coming from
individuality in general as we saw it
called just a few paragraphs before in
the last paragraph now how its Hegel
going to phrase this though he says in
this relation it also has in itself it
is also in itself where he has intrinsic
being this aspect belongs to the
unchangeable Beyond and consists of what
faculties and powers what is then well
when we think about what it means to
think there's an individual thinking
that's happening right now for example
you're thinking about this but what are
you thinking with you're thinking with a
lot by itself or are you thinking with
your intellect are you thinking with
your power of reasoning are you thinking
with your mind I'm moving around from
place to place this is a Faculty of
locomotion
as you know the ancients of the
medievals would call these faculties and
powers our general and we're going to
see an interesting interplay occur here
now as we move into the next paragraphs
these are the in itself of the
individual consciousness how it uses
those determinately is it's for itself
here